uh Vice media nears a deal for 400
million dollars sale go down a little
bit out of a bankruptcy no no let me
just read at the top I'm sorry I was
just saying to be able to read the top
yeah the media businesses talks to sell
itself to top lenders Fortress
investment and Soros fundament
s
isn't that weird reorganization that
would wipe out other investors Now look
up 250 million debt financing Soros Vice
let's stay on that real quick and then
go back go go to the 250 million dollars
let me just read the bottom and then go
to that go up a little bit I just want
to see what else is yeah right there
right there there is a fortress 400
million dollars nearly every Vice stock
holder including backers such as private
Equity Room tpg 6th Street and Mogul
gens would be wiped out under the
proposed organization wow people
familiar with the matter outstanding
debts held by tpg63 would be impaired as
part of the plan that people said the
Murdoch family is a major shareholder in
the journal parent News Corp the plant
cell of the company of its lenders with
the value of I said around 400 million
dollars including debt the people sent a
steep drop from 5.7 million okay now go
to the 250 million dollars
Vice media gets 250 million dollar debt
funding from
and so this is debt funding so what
they're saying now is that 400 million
evaluation includes the debt he already
had so what does that mean not to
mention earlier this I think it was
earlier this year they got 30 million
dollars in debt financing I imagine it
might have been from Soros so we're
talking about they're sitting on 280
million dollars in debt is that 400 what
is that 400 million dollar evaluation
mean that Soros fund is buying the
company for 120 million
right right because he's not going to
pay his own debt back assuming the debt
and Brett or however much they may have
paid back so so people point out the
Soros thing and I'm like yeah that was
that was four years ago
but you know my view of it was there was
a uh there was an article that was out
uh came out a long time ago and it was a
little cartoon animation they made of
Shane Smith with a frying pan and a book
in it and he was flipping it because
they said that he was cooking the books
and uh what they accuse him of doing I
don't know if it's true okay I'm just
saying this is this is a big narrative
that um he would do this very clever
thing where he would say this year we
put a million we put a billion dollars
on the books
what does that really mean well to the
average person who doesn't know much
about the industry or business or
Finance or Deals they think he added a
billion dollars in Revenue what he's
actually saying is we did a 10 10 year
we did a 30-year deal I love this one we
did a I just I just uh gave a guy uh
this is what the casino does near me
they say you could win one million
dollars if you enter this raffle in the
bottom and fine print it says 25 000 a
year for 40 years oh great great so
they're going to give you two grand per
month for 40 years maybe the average age
of the person at the casino is not going
to live for four years but they call it
giving you a million bucks very very
clever financing this is marketing but
that's an annuity though most life
insurance
Lottery uh winners get an annuity the
point is though when you you are told
enter this contest for a chance to win a
million dollars and what they're
actually saying is 25k a year is a very
very different you think you get a
million dollars what I'm saying to you
is what they're telling you is we're
giving you million dollar annuity that's
that's what they're saying an annuity is
you know when you win the lottery if you
win 100 million dollars if you take the
whole thing up front you're going to get
taxed what 50 percent yeah you're gonna
get 40 you're gonna get 40. you're gonna
end up getting 50 million bucks let's
just say 40 million bucks versus you
take an annuity and you say I'm gonna
take this 100 million dollars over a
40-year period okay then you're gonna
get two and a half million bucks every
year for 40 years that's an option and
you pay less tax the point is
if I walked up to the average person and
said if you buy a raffle ticket from me
you could win one million dollars
they're not expecting to get two
thousand dollars per month for 40 years
they think my life will change I'll buy
a house I get that so I just think that
part you know there's a lot of things I
don't again I don't know these guys I
don't know what they're doing I mean my
concern is a whole different concern my
concern is if you go to an investor yeah
and say we need a hundred million
dollars to expand and we just put 300
million on the books this year yeah
what do you think that investor is
thinking I mean look at any Savvy
investor is going to be like what does
that mean on the books this year but
there's a clever thing that was being
done in media in the 2010s well it was
called um ad rights assignments or ad
rights sales all of these media
companies would take their gold standard
brand they'd pay for Let's uh let's
let's call it splice just a random word
related to an unrelated company and uh
they would say get uh 30 million views
per month
they would then go to another website
that generate a click form you ever see
those articles where it's like you won't
believe where the celebrity is now yeah
and it's like 25 photos you click it and
then there's 800 ads and one picture of
Tom Cruise you click next it loads a new
page that's click farming that is the
worst and then you're not now you're
seven pages in you're like I gotta go
what the hell where the hell is Tom
Cruise where's Tom Cruise here's how it
works and it probably still happens
today
splice would go to that company and say
sell us the rights to sell ads on your
views and they would say you got it
splice would then say the 50 million
garbage views from that trash website
are now a part of splice views they
would then go to advertise and say the
splice Network gets 80 million views per
month don't you want to be a part of it
the advertiser thinks they're buying the
gold standard of content what they don't
realize is their ads are being assigned
to a garbage clickbait website no one
actually reads your beef is it sounds
like it at least on the surface sort of
a bait and switch type of deal but
here's I think it's fraud but here's
what I love about about you know what
you're saying and a lot of people do
that they all did it too yeah he's
absolutely and by the way there's
another magazine that we were trying to
buy six months ago Tom and Mario know
about this one here we're on a call with
them and remember back in the days when
people would buy fake YouTube views and
you know it would show 17 million views
17 comments I said dude you did not get
70 million and you could buy these views
I'm like well I'm gonna go buy views I'm
gonna go buy views and then Twitter you
can buy a million followers for five
thousand dollars and you're getting two
retweets or one retweet right he knows
this this was running even when uh I
don't know what Gingrich or they did
Obama thing on his uh followers 75
percent of followers on Twitter was fake
or whatever the number was this was on
one of the elections that took place but
here's the thing if you do that
say you sell advertisers there's this
magazine that sold this show to a big
phone company okay and I'm listening to
the pitch and they said we got 28
million views it's the number one show
it's competing with Shark Tank I'm
watching the show because I was invited
to be one of the hosts on the show I'm
like guys I know YouTube You Know
YouTube this is how you're selling it to
this phone company yeah
you're not getting these views as a
YouTuber I know show me your AdSense on
the back and how many if you're saying
this thing got 70 million views how much
money did you make on this how many
advert how did you get 17 million views
but only 28 cents on revenue on this
video the point becomes that strategy
that a lot of guys did in 2010s and he's
right a lot did it they did it on
YouTube they did on Twitter today you
know what the advertisers are finally
listening they're learning okay we'll
test you out for one ad two ads three
ads dude we got no conversion we're not
coming back and then if you have a
reputation of people dropping you over
and over and over again
all they're going to say is yeah these
ads don't convert because you have just
as much of a job if you bring in a
sponsor to convert theirs he knows this
as they do they may give you a hundred
grand or 200 Grand or half a million
dollars but they're expecting is this
going to convert or not but what if then
you uh get those 70 million views or
whatever disable comments and just and
then you go to a network and say our
show of 10 episodes got 7 million views
each uh we don't like the comments
because people have hate speech well if
the advertisers want to do that the
advertisers the network buys the show
from you I get no no well then the
network who buys the show
uh have to go in the category of
qualified morons and that's totally fine
and that's going to happen as well
there's a lot of them out there yep and
they're doing a lot it happened a lot
well you're right it happened a lot and
a lot of people got money and you know
let's not forget what YouTube did just
two and a half years ago three years ago
when they said you can no longer put the
you know thumbs down or when Biden was
speaking the thumbs down was gone you
couldn't see comments were disabled and
nobody wanted to even today when they go
on C-Span or some of these different
places comments are disabled you can't
see in the desk so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]